four degrees outside right now guys and
of course winds are blowing you can see
the tower cam behind me that's at
rainbow and west cliff
there's a flag there are the palm trees
right here okay
we have seen gusts up to 40 out of
mccarran of course up the northwest part
of the valley too
those winds are blowing and we're seeing
those winds all across
across the valley and the region right
now 60 in centennial hills at the sour
summerlin at 57
the temperatures are dropping big time
but the patches of that front
60 and leonte 64 for downtown
and the lake is coming at 63 degrees
elsewhere the east side
coming in also in the 69 degree mark for
sunrise mountain same goes for green
valley henderson 64.
rhodes ranch mountains edge at 66 or 60
degrees
that includes southern highlands too
just prepare for a chilly night tonight
with those winds and a chilly morning
too
59 for prompt 66 boulder city and
laughlin checking in right now
at 75 degrees let's get to the doppler
network now
there are no these are false echoes
right now on our radar but it is
sweeping around
picking up some snow showers actually up
near cedar city and that's about it that
front sliding through
we'll see those winds really wrap up
from the north and this is what we're
going to get
strong gusts now could be up to 40 in
some locations or more that's the reason
for that wind advisory
all the way through tomorrow morning
even during the morning commute we'll
see those winds decrease
more during the day tomorrow especially
the afternoon hours that's when they'll
really start to relax more so really
prepare for
a gusty morning especially if you're
traveling or state route 160
we'll have some very strong gusts from
your commute from prompt or
over to perum here's what we're going to
see also the result with the passage of
that front
73 today and then a big cooldown
tomorrow look at that 10 degrees 63
degrees our high for tomorrow and that
is it here's your evening planner 63 at
7 p.m
windy same goes for 9 p.m 57 degrees 8
news at 11 will be at the top all right
to let you know about those winds
before you go to bed 54 degrees at 11
o'clock and still those gusty winds
tomorrow morning two for your morning
commute for the good day team we'll keep
you updated on that too
here is your most accurate eight on the
eight your eight day forecast
breezy winds continue again on saturday
and sunday with another front that's
going to knock back our temperatures to
the low 60s
we're hoping we get some rain drops next
week but right now all the models are
indicating that
we're going to stay dry at least right
now mostly sunny skies and temperatures
closer to
70. not bad next week that's your most
accurate forecast we'll see at 11
denise yeah